-Testing!
-Okay. Quiet, please!
-This is Scene 50, take 1.
Scene 50. Alright.
♪♪
-We're back in the building.
We're back in the studio.
And it's great.
It gives us a lot of opportunity
to do more topical things
that we've been wanting to do.
We did Harry Styles.
We parodied Billie Eilish's
video hours after it came out.
Even her people were like,
"How did you pull this off?"
It's our genius wardrobe
and our hair and makeup.
Tonight, we're doing something,
the biggest thing
that we've done so far, I think,
as far as pulling something off.
We're spoofing "WandaVision."
-The writers came up with
"FallonVision,"
which was basically a fun way
for us to do some sets
that were historical
sort of talk shows.
And so, we would bounce
through the ages
and we would have
different sets,
and Jimmy would be in different
costumes and all that stuff.
-As long as
you're not thinking --
As long as you're not thinking
this man.
-Yeah.
-Know what I mean?
It's off of the man man.
-Yeah.
-Then into a theater scene.
And I think kind of look around
again, like, you know.
Ha-ha!
-Yep.
-This came together
super fast --
three or four days.
We have very limited space,
so we madly drafted some things,
built it overnight,
and just got it here
as quick as we could
and tried to kind of piece it
together to get the right look.
-Ladies and gentlemen,
welcome to "The Tonight Show."
Good evening.
I'm Jimmy Fallon,
broadcasting live in color
from Rock Center.
We back? Cool.
Welcome back, guys.
I'm here with Elizabeth Olsen.
The way I got into each
character before we did it
was very -- it was so fun.
Again, we're very lucky to have
great wardrobe and hair.
But once you're in the wig,
or you can even see
on a little monitor
which is, you know, 20 feet away
that it's black and white
and kind of kinescope-looking,
so your voice can be
very kind of stiff.
-Action!
-Ladies and gentlemen,
welcome to "The Tonight Show."
Right now, I'm joined
by a lovely lady,
an actress by the name
of Miss Elizabeth Olsen.
Then there's also decades where
people were, like, just smoking.
Cigarettes. As a host.
And I'm -- I do not
smoke cigarettes,
and so that was some really good
acting on my part.
-What hand do you smoke with?
Left, right?
-Pssh!
Right, I guess? I don't smoke.
-[ Laughs ]
-We had some smokers on the crew
that were just like...
"Guy. That is not how --
Oh, whatever."
I'm just, like, shaking.
You know, there's a '90s set.
It's kind of a very
Conan O'Brien vibe,
where it's just, like,
wacky graphics.
You know, at the time,
you know, it's normal.
We're here with
a crazy-talented actress.
You know her, you love her --
Lizzie Olsen, guys!
Uh, Liz, need a chill pill?
-We asked Elizabeth Olsen
would she be into
filming with us, like, a parody
where Jimmy travels through time
and she's always the guest
on the show.
And she said yes, but she was
in London filming "Dr. Strange."
So we shipped her props
and wigs and costume,
but it didn't get there in time,
so she basically --
here and her team shot it
by themselves,
then they sent a bunch of really
great footage on Monday.
-So, our kind of secret
twist ending to this
is that it's all done
by Kathryn Hahn,
who plays Agnes
on "WandaVision."
Not only did she come through,
but, man, she came through!
Unbelievable pro,
and crushed it.
[ Static ]
-But if it wasn't you,
then who was it?
[ Static ]
-Ohh, poor Elizabeth.
[ Applause ]
-Wait. K-Kathryn Hahn?!
What are you doing here?
-What can I say?
TV just isn't
what it used to be.
[ Laughter ]
[ Ding ]
-♪ Who's been messing up
everything? ♪
-♪ It's been Kathryn Hahn
all along ♪
-Alright. Good to see you guys.
Please stay safe and healthy.
-You too.
-Likewise. Thank you again.
-Bye!
-We love doing this.
We want to do more of this.
This was just the beginning
of what I think the potential
that we have to do
here at "The Tonight Show,"
even with limited resources
and a limited crew.
We're just gonna push ourselves.
We're all on the same team.
We want people to be like,
"How did they pull this off?"
Especially in these times
where we don't know
what's gonna happen,
we just want to make you happy
and we want to entertain people.
And we're just getting going.
Watch us.